you've met them all who's the celebrity
you're most excited to meet I mean in
present company excluded
but you've met all the big ones you know
well I you know you you I guess the most
exciting celebrity to meet is someone
not anyone in your peer group because
you're competitive with them and you
want their failure but when you're 12
and 11 and the big stars of that time
are the ones and I would say of all the
people that I've met through years the
one that I could not believe I was
meeting was George Harrison oh wow you
met George Harrison I got high with
George Harris oh wow
I got high no I know I'll take what
happened it was 1990 and this fabulous
Hollywood couple that I won't reveal
their names phoned me up and said we're
having dinner party how would you like
to meet up Beatle and I said yeah I
would George Harrison they were gonna
have George Harrison or you should have
said which one I know I know I know well
I don't have that kind of wit anyway so
so my wife dancing are very excited
we're listening a rubber sole the whole
way right preparing it she wouldn't she
said at one point wouldn't be great just
to corner him and as much as he'd hate
I'd say what's it like being a Beatle
how great was it tell me everything
about the nine years when you're a
Beatle right so of course we laughed
we'd never do that then we got there and
there were a lot of fabulous people
there about ten and they were gonna show
the film a hunt for red october but and
then george walked in and he looked
exactly like george harrison i mean it
was perfect he looked and he was so
fabulous and one point he said does
anyone want to hear my new Wilburys
album so he was brain damaged a buddy
with my mouth full of chocolate I didn't
say I was an impersonator hold on
if only Hepburn had been there has
anyone worried how my world he said do
not clean my wheels blues album yeah I
said sure would and so he put it on and
all of us heard gathering around but
like any musician as some one goes into
two goes into three you know people are
drifting away to the bar but I'm hanging
right with him
sure and then as people would come back
with like an hors d'oeuvre he'd sing
lyrics in their face to try to get them
back into the album a Beatle trying to
convince people to listen he's so
enthusiastic and I was you know there's
and it was by the way it was the second
whoa Brazil was brilliant he couldn't
have been more delightful couldn't have
been more fun and loose and immediately
friendly and what you'd hope he'd be and
then later on and then throughout dinner
we kind of lost track of each other and
he sat with other people more important
people and then at the end we're now
about to watch The Hunt for Red October
and it's my director friend the host and
his wife and my wife and me and then
George sits here and and then my
director friend says does anyone mind if
I smoke a doobie because we're about to
watch Hunt for Red October and we all
say no no so he takes a puff and then he
passes to a wife she takes a puff and it
passes to my wife and she takes a puff
and she coughs and that she faked and
then it's passed to me and I take a
little puff and I think who do I pass it
to George will I offend him with a
Maharishi Mahesh Yogi be mad at me is it
a thing not to do should know I said I'd
to hell with it
just pass it to George Harrison and he
took anyone ah the sixties
[Laughter]
and then and then he then he took a puff
and then he started talking really
loudly and way too loud for a screening
he was talking to me and at one point
he's you know I can't watch Sean Connery
because he's it's like watching a Beatle
he's too famous and the second he said
beetle my wife popped up like that it's
a beetle
did someone say beetle I'm here I'm back
and then someone told us to shush and
then there was quiet and I said way to
go [ __ ]